so so my presentation is on Hajj
epidemic among MSM and transgender
people in India I'll be talking about
the current situation and what are the
current national responses and the gaps
this is the outline of my presentation
like I will just provide a brief
overview of the Kiche epidemic in India
and then I will talk about the various
subgroups of ms of interest general
people in India then about HIV and STI
prevalence among MSM and transgender and
achieve elated with behaviors among them
and about structural violence and stigma
fish by MSM and transgender people and
national response was I finally like
gaps and challenges this presentation is
partly based on a technical report which
I prepared for wh 0 Southeast Asia
office so this is actually for each
country supper time presenting only on
India but I have I'm providing like
updated information and I'm also like
maybe talk about little bit about my
studies also along with this
presentation ok we trigger to the
general overview of the nachay pandemic
in india as you all know like you might
have heard that India was the leading
the hot chili liqueur in it was the
having the largest number of people in
HIV about maybe phone years back now it
is in the third question now it's the
third largest country with having the
people luna the TV like no the
estimation is like a bochur 2.2 3
million people living with HIV at the
end of two thousand eight so previously
it was like about five million like
about soundman's seven years ago and
actually the infection in there was fast
like identified among female sex workers
from Chennai in 1986 so that was one
reason why like Dell wazza you're
negligent the focus of focus on sex
between men because it was widely
thought like it was primarily decade for
epidemic which is driving the polemic
only after like ten years at the
National AIDS Control organization
acknowledged like la risa epidemic among
men who else equipment that that was the
official statement only after like in
1987 like nearly like 10 years of the
after the epidemic so if you look at the
[ __ ] prevalence in the general
population it is a very literally very
low like point winning percentage but if
when you compare that with the risk
groups what the nacco calls us code high
risk groups Nyko is the india's national
aids control organization so it's nearly
like like 10 to 20 times higher than the
general population rate so this you can
see the decrease in the adult has a
prevalence in India leg from point 4 5
percentage to fine-tuning percentage
recently and this is the estimated
number of rippling with the chair I told
you like it's 2.2 7 million actually
they revised the estimates like
previously it was like here which was
like 5 million based on the National
Family Health Survey they actually like
the waist retrospectively all these
numbers so that's why I like I can see
like it's like 2.7 million here like
because it was like 85 million at the
time okay I say at all like the hot a
prevalence among the the co populations
you can see like the mean has a
prevalence among MSM is like 7.4
percentage and among injecting drug
users 9.2 percentage and female sex
workers 4.9 percentage so this could be
because like there have been like a lot
of interventions among female sex
workers since the epidemic that's why it
is now actually the lowest among the
what the neck across the high risk
groups but of course I ideas also like
it's quite high like because it was also
not addressed properly by the Indian
government until recently
okay the sonechko has estimated the size
the population size of mini classic
statement so according to nagios
estimation like there's a total number
of above 2.3 million member sex with men
in india a cartesian after they had some
formula and they've come out with this
and now neck also says like there's a
plug approximately point 23 million male
sex workers in india but however we
don't have any reliable estimates for a
he draws our male to female transgender
people but for program purposes nay co
wants to state laker there's a
population of vulture point three
million hi this commission which nay co
wants to target for catch a prevention
work so the coverage of the hatch a
prevention program is actually based on
this number so this is actually dignus
like the hundred percentage so this this
so what do we mean by high-risk amazon
according to knock oh it's like if it's
more than fifteen partners per month
sonoco is going to it is saying like we
will talk it only like those people like
we're having more than fifteen
participant man it's like a of course we
can't able to find out like we're having
that many number of partners the
assumption is like it because the nacco
has primary fight [ __ ] targeted
interventions people who will come into
the closing fights they are more likely
to have large number of partners and
that's why i like that that's the
assumption by the neck oh okay so and
there are various studies which have
shown that like the prevalence of
same-sex behavior among indian men is
varies from anywhere from six to 13
percentage some of these studies have
been done among general populations and
some all from the STD clinic attendees
so this is just to like show how the
five estimation compares with that of
other these groups like this is like a
10 lag is 1 million so this like point
three million MSM like 1.2 million
female sex workers I'd use like point 1
million okay so that's just to provide a
brief or will be about the hedge
epidemic in India now I'm really talk
about the various subgroups of MSM in
India okay so MSM as you know is like a
behavioral category so any men who have
sex with other men they have a label
does like minerals excitement regardless
of the sexual identity or sexual
orientation so so so in India also like
does the common term is like main course
exit men are sometimes they may use like
males who have sex with males but at the
major proportion of Memphis exit men in
India or those people who do not have a
self conscious homosexual identity so
that's I think may be true in other
developing countries are even in
developed countries so even in May like
clinical factors like I i have seen like
people men who may come and tell like
they had sex with men but they will say
like yes I had sex with a homosexual so
they don't see themselves as a
homosexual sure they will say because
there are some delicate returns in
Indian languages so they will only use
that term to the Phi I had sex with like
for example in Tamil there's a valley
called would call poor type is a
delegate term so they will use that term
yes I had sex with the poor time so they
will see themselves as only a man
because we don't have any terms for
heterosexual in Indian languages nobody
calls themself a sketch effectual the
heat so sexuals because there's no term
like this noise so they think like I'm a
man okay man I get sex with like a
feminine person okay so i think that
that will be the commonest category
among men were six sigma
but unfortunately because all these size
based target interventions are like at
the goosing sites and majority of them
are actually used by people who
self-identify themselves for scotty's or
double deckers I am going to talk about
that so this particular population is
actually left out like so nowadays like
nago use a system called hard to reach
MSM to talk about these non-identified
ms and because it's difficult to reach
out to them and and maybe i will just
for the discussion purposes i will just
simplify we can see like based on the
class differences some differences in
the identities people who are from the
lower socioeconomic class and who was
same-sex attracted some proportion they
may identify themselves as cotys so
cotys are like people who are same-sex
attracted males but they are feminine
and cool mainly receptive partners in
sex with men ok so the cote is like
pan-indian term it is like a used all
over india as well as even in actually
in pakistan and bengal but there are
some regional variations like for
example in Manipur they just choose the
English alphabet a so AMS nvm Islam so a
is like a feminine like B is like
masculine person and they have a B
person who penetrates and disease so
like so cotys they call the masculine
partners as panties so punk please
according to coat these are supposed to
be like Hitler sexuals so but they they
they are like masculine the penetrate
but they have like heterosexual they're
mainly main attraction gives to its like
women but once in a while they have sex
with them so that's why they call like
punty as a like a real man so they want
to have sex only with real men so Cote
and panty and panties label given by
coty panthi is not an identity but
nowadays it's also like becoming
identity some people they start
identifying themselves for spunky and i
actually like i have seen in
when mixed in Mexico conference there
was one person in the session who
identified himself as I am an
unidentified msi so it was like I I
thought it wasn't I thought it was a
joke it wasn't it wasn't he clearly told
her he is not edit videos so and code is
called those persons who like penetrate
friendly feel as like double deckers so
so again like double decker used to be
like a I like a label label given by the
cooties but nowadays again it's becoming
an identity people started identifying
themselves as a double decker so so
there are some visual variations in the
other terms like somewhere it is called
as double and somewhere it's like dupli
doable at up for example in Calcutta so
there are some regional variations in
this dump however even though we talk
about like the based on the gender
expression there's a varying degree
degree of feminine itching among Cote so
it need not be like obviously feminine
and also like cotys can also like
penetrate but the assumption if like
code is not supposed to like penetrate
ok and people who call from the middle
and upper class again like majority of
them they may not have any conscious in
sex sexual identity but some proportion
they may identify themselves as gay and
some some very very ugly like some very
minor proportion also identify then
sulfus bisexual ok I'm coming to like
transgender people like there are
several terms which are used to I think
the common terms which you might be
aware least like hydras other one is
used in Tamil Nadu like these are like
used in other parts of India job te
llama ass exactly and hid among the head
rest before the operation the sex change
operation or removal of the male
external genitalia they call themselves
as aqua aqua is equivalent to pre-op hu
transsexual and after the operation they
call themself as new one near one-hitter
so new one is like a post operating and
some people are like non operation no
the hitch was the main arch also like
under the operation at any point in time
like so that's briefly about the major
subgroups I just wanted to show some
photos or like not to like show that
like they are like difference there like
in if you see them on the road you may
not be able to identify I'm just want to
like just to show that like the slimes
the like a community-based agency where
I have my research projects with in
chennai so you can see like they
primarily work with coty identified msn
of course when you look at this you may
not able to tell who is like ot of
double of frontal so okay this lick from
the drop-in center of swam again okay so
punty anybody who is masculine is plenty
so there is like a currency code is like
any button anybody who is like ms client
is a potential sexual partners so this
person is like a hyper masculine like so
she can be like anything as clean person
is like a pontic okay so he just saw
this leg from the from a particular book
cover like a Jewess cool yeah of course
I now anomaly is like wearing in India
like they are not using the terms
unix-like because it's not like a proper
term to use again this is a person like
a schedule a person from actually not
thieves yeah a person like a transgender
person now that does also like
differences between like some people may
they have male to female transgender but
they don't identify themselves for
schedule for example this a particular
charge needed activists she doesn't
minute one child interfaith herself as a
caterer but she married in phase SI my
transgender women
okay so that that's about the subgroups
now coming to the high prevalence among
MSM in TG see we are the whatever data
we have is primarily from like one is
from the government data national HIV
service of data other thing is actually
from the allergen legates funded
projects like integrated biological and
behavioral assessment and also there are
a couple of other data from my
colleagues who are clinics from the
Comanche we've taken organizations
working with Amazon so apart from that
like we don't have actually very much
like diverse of data sources on hot a
prevalence among MSM so I in two
thousand year the government co-solvent
sites were like about 56 sites for MSM
and there was only one side for to have
gender people so actually we don't know
much about like the prevalence of like
HIV among transgender people but
whatever data we have it so it is very
well I'm going to just talk about that
all's so here you can see we already
told about the mean has a prevalence of
hm ammonium sm it's about like seven
point four percentage but there are
obviously like variations according to
different / aids or different regions so
these are like I am just showing like
four different states for the five so
the Andhra Pradesh Tamil Nadu and
Karnataka southern states maharashtra
it's like whiffed delhi is in North you
can see maybe a sub maharashtra effete
maharashtra my gosh i have a decreasing
trend and everything else actually
there's an increasing trend I'm not
actually showing like the house 2007 29
data but like it's still provisional
from neck or so nanako hasn't confirmed
that so that calls up but it shows like
increasing trend in all these three
states like Tamil Nadu Andhra Pradesh
Karnataka there's an increasing trend
but maybe you know about like the
decreasing trend of catch a prevalence
in southern states like in India and
among the general population
but in contrast to that actually doesn't
increase in at a prevalence among MSM
from the famous Italian states where the
interventions are working among the
general population ok so if Jay
prevalence data actually we have very
little very little data because
government they don't have a yes case of
a surveillance they only have like HIV
but show maybe only from the tamil nadu
government they have some safe avenge
data and again this is from the allergen
data and the one of that it's actually
from my study like so it's mama it's
like this really fluffy fleece
prevalence like lab confirm syphilis
like it's about it varies from a to like
14 percentage syphilis and other if
chief actually like we don't have much
data this data is only from the IBB a
like integrated biological and video
surveillance of allergen program so it's
like chlamydia is like 12 4 percentage
and go na VI is less than 1 percentage
so that's the only data we have but we
don't have much data about the viral ft
ice actually
is this it's a video of an yeah so the
video having yeah really other than
keeping it yeah yeah this is yeah yeah
okay yeah you can look at like the FJ
prevents among us is like Mumbai like 57
percentage they had like a syphilis and
hatch a prevalence I think I did not
mention that high prevalence rates about
it can be anywhere from like 20
percentage and like 240 percentage in
Mumbai it was like at one point in time
it was like a cheap Evelyn's 40
percentage and now it's about 18 to 20
percentage among hitters okay coming to
the catch a related this baby's I we
have data primarily on the sexiest
babies but we also have little data
about on jag if behaviors also okay so
so MSM just like anybody else like they
have all type of sexual partners are
regular partners cash was a commercial
or paying partners and MSM even though
we we say like men who have sex with men
they also have sex with a female we may
not select some of them they also have
sex with transgender people and just to
give an idea about the number of male
partners because nanko talks about like
a more than 15 partners per month US
highways so so you can see like the BSS
data gesture like 12 15 in bang I'm just
looking good giving an idea in bangalore
and twitter 34 commercial partners and
so the prevalence of Valium thank you
okay and this is the percentage of MSM
who have like sex with women also like
it varies from like nearly 12.6
percentage to about 70 percentage so
gather quite regional variations and
actually if you look at like this slope
the if it is where if you see this is a
low actually like or in the future lens
some sites like the
age group majority of the age group are
like less than 30 years but many of them
they get married like back 25 years 30
years and even after that so we hope
that the most of them will eventually
get married and this prevalence like
this this post proportion maybe actually
like even which we hire actually like
its need not be like a like 12
percentage because many of them they get
eventually marriage women because of
variety of reasons okay condom use is a
again about cha 132 two types of MSM
they reported not using condoms during
last anal sex with a male partner this
is like a BSS our data be a behavioral
surveillance survey of government in
2006 they haven't actually believe the
data from 2009 yet again like I'm not
sure whether they have mentioned here
the condom use with the steady partners
is low compared to that of with casual
partners or even like fake partners and
okay and also especially the condom use
with female partners again like it's
very low compared to the male partners
and especially with the wife like it may
be a very very low because of variety of
reasons like they may be afraid of metal
discs are the other wife might have
already undergone Cuba tahmeed she would
question why the husband is using
condoms now all of the sudden okay and
what a bit lubricants are are not like
commonly used by majority of msn because
it's not widely available i also like
it's at the cost is high because it's
primarily available as like tubes that
it will cost about like a 92 the piece
of hundreds of bits it's like two
dollars but it's still costly for my
majority of them okay just is like
consistency of condom use among MSM with
commercial male partners you can so
comfort with 2001 data you can see like
there's a definite increase in
consistency of condom use like so it
varies from like about nineteen percent
age to about fifty three percentage so
yeah yes see all these cities nako have
programs so they they are that so they
take these two thousand one of the
baseline and then they followed up after
like but it's like of course it is not
like a covert it's like a sample of
their MSM population from those cities
so in all these actually they have
interventions going on so even in areas
valve interventions going on you can see
it's the conditions of economies is like
less than 60 percentage so in actually
in the next picture like these are like
new for example in with the puter polish
that have never been like an
intervention so you can see the condom
use like it's like less than 13
percentage so these like a newly added
sites but actually they were having like
interventions here like move only the
fights were new making 2006 otherwise
they were having interventions but you
can see like where wherever there was no
like interventions there's a very low
consistency in of condom use okay but
this one is actually among like a
non-commercial male partner actually
they did not provide details about like
a steady partners and casual partners if
we want to show a graph it isn't like
between now steady partner versus other
casual partners sorry with casual
partners then I think like you will be
quite different with study partners it
will be very very low okay and also we
have very limited information about
sexual if because of her type of MSM and
transgender people I have done some
studies one is like a myth myth of
studies another which this is a
qualitative study so but only these two
actually studies are available
specifically on her Jeep Austria maximum
translator so whatever studies are which
are available that actually indicate
like how this behaviors among hijae
pajamas and putting
surface at risk for other infection as
well as like putting the partner sources
so that's actually definite need for the
positive prevention programs in India
because the nyko is also talking about
pasta prevention but actually they
haven't developed any strategy for like
implementing the positive prevention
programs among what they call the
general plhiv as well lets up piacere
from people you need to save from other
populations okay drug you saw again your
diff information X again from behaviors
for Vince data like 2006 primarily in
Delhi actually there's a high percentage
of MSM who reported like injecting it's
nearly 30 percentage majority of these
like drugs or like he lying or
dextropropoxyphene like they call a
spasm proximal and also pharmaceutical
drugs so it's by primarily a cocktail of
pharmaceutical drugs so those are the
common injections which are used I don't
think like no nobody has documented like
for example myth and fit I mean crystals
no we havin sure like documented anyone
any one of those in India its primary
like a hero in and pharmaceutical
injections and in two thousand you can
see like nine in Chennai Kolkata andhra
pradesh like which one Nona from the
from this data from this data from the
2006 basis data vic does not like in the
past one year they did not but it's
actually i also related to the sometimes
the drug control measures so for jelly
in china which is close to ft lanka have
the drug peddling drugs smuggling
happening there's a very strict
enforcement off for like they will clean
every one and therefore actually most of
them they move into like non injecting
drug use or they may use a cocktail of
the local medications like faded use
sleeping pills so that that's why i like
they may not actually that depends on
the question they ask if they are asked
like they do you
like here I mean or something like that
so maybe they will they would have say
no but if they asked something else
maybe they would have feathers okay and
again you can see like if we include
include like non injecting drug use also
again from Delhi it's the highest so
nearly 50 percentage is reported any
intoxicating drug use so diff actually
like includes maybe something like the
con job marijuana okay but you can see
like it's also like reported in other
fit is like from Bangalore as well as of
course it's still like from lawyers from
Chen f ok so that's about briefly about
the HIV related with behaviors now come
just briefly about the structural
violence and stigma because it's
primarily because this poses are both
direct whiskas Olaf indirect risk for
getting HIV and for transmitting HIV so
I think most of you might have heard
about the Delhi High Court verdict that
they have wet down section 377 which
criminalized certain knowing virginal
sexual practices actually because it was
actually criminal to have en el sexo
oral sex even between husband and wife
so so so that's why I like section V
Foundation was actually not about like a
criminal life in same-sex be here it was
actually like criminal FML anything any
non virgin and sexual practices between
two adults ok so what the hot Delhi High
Court did was each side like we can read
down section 377 so what they mean by
beat down is like it will be no longer
applicable if it is if the sex happens
between two adults in a consensual
manner in prevage so that's what they
they mean however like does there has
been appeal against this judgment
because it's a high coach it's not like
supreme court so there's an appeal
against this and that's actually going
to hearing
in june of july in the 15 coach so still
it's in the coach so you may think like
india has actually like legalized no
it's not it's still like it's in the
quote actually so and in relation to
section is again like negative attitude
towards same sex sexuality and stigma
attached to being her shape of to MSM of
transgender it's also it has
considerable implications on people like
talking openly about like HIV they've
score if they are at a posture they may
not want to come out openly a sketchy
posture it is the same thing for whether
they are careful factual so whether they
are like homosexual persons okay and
actually if the the stigma attached true
like I even if a person is a feminine
person your feminine person in posture
like then the person may be seen as okay
this person is more likely to be like a
homosexual because you also see the
gender expression as like a proxy for
the homosexual orientation so this also
use string attached to being feminine so
i will talk about that what what we can
say as gender nonconformity stigma the
graves that's one of my study actually
area interested area okay so you can
look at this paper of mine like
structural violence against côte need
for MSM in india in which we talked
about that was in 2007 so at that time
still section 377 was in charge so
because even the you there was like
pollies who are actually raping Minkus
exit men so it's like they could not
able to report any factual values to the
police so it's like it's quite difficult
that's why I like but even now because
majority of these MSM who was standing
in the closing sites they are also
engaging in sex work even though section
347 you can say like has been let down
majority of this MSM in sex work they
made the police may say you are in sex
work sex work is still like like illegal
even though being a sex worker is not
illegal a standing on a public place and
so
fitting is illegal in india so skin like
that is our ongoing like sexual violence
from police and the fence which are
faced by MSM who are with stink lifting
fights and there's a new new form of
like blackmail because of increase in
internet use people who are evenly
previously actually like only majority
of the cote identified ms I'm they used
to face violence now it is because of
the increase in internet use Internet
has also been used as to blackmail
people use that of a trap to bring the
presence to some areas and then the
blackmail and then they start mining
even from people who may not have any
identity or people who may identify as
gay ok this is this dis the study which
i mentioned like so this is this like a
pilot study which I have just completed
so it actually looked at the influence
of the impact of sexual stigma gender
nonconformity stigma and catch a later
stigma on the mental health status
depression and sexual with behaviors so
this we have found that child there it
does a definite impact the like nearly
like fifty to fifty percentage of the
MSM in the sample 200 samples they had a
severe depression moderate or severe
depression scores okay I'm coming to the
National responses finally okay so
currently we are in the third phase of
National AIDS Control Program and the
third phase is going to end in 2012 next
year and that's why you know now there's
a fourth phase planning is developed
happening now and only in two thousand
six and seven like there was a
development of operational guidelines
for target interventions among MSM
before that there was actually none only
from the third phase of the national
program they explicitly mentioned MSM
and transgender in the strategic plan of
the government before that it was not at
all that and national a chance of
organization provides funds to state it
control society which are like state
government uh thanks flyweights support
to the non-governmental organizations
and CB o--'s working with MSM or other
populations so this is the like funding
fun flow and recently like nagging has
also developed are what they call NGO
CBO transition guidelines because we
differentiate in India we differentiate
F even the fee beers are NGOs CBO's are
all only managed by the community people
for example the fever's in the fee do
all the board members will be who are
for example MSM are all the board
members who are electric circus so
that's why you like nagger ones are the
teal the targeted intervention to be
directly implemented through the Phoebe
rose and so therefore this actually like
transition from the NGO to the free
booze okay so these are the main
components of the MSM Chie like behave
change communication condom promotion
and distribution yes to a treatment of
all the fur jacket of string and
creation of enabling environment this
creation of enabling image actually like
only limited to talking to the local
police people about the tulare
intervention is not actually like
bringing decreasing the stigma in the
local communities it's not like that but
again one obvious a gap is insufficient
a budget for water-based lubricants are
in the national program okay so summing
the t is the two kind of targeted
intervention when is called when we can
cause us like exclusive target
intervention an ellipse the Campos aye
tis so excluded SQ 50s or only
exclusively for men who have sex with
men so there are about 132 TI's working
working exclusively among MSM and
actually among these like terrified well
managed by sea views are we're now in
january two thousand chain so on each ta
is supposed to cover about 400 250
amazon for ya blinch na that are
actually three TS so it's like now the
actually [ __ ] wants to be more
efficient and it wants HTH to cover the
800 msn so I part surface efficiency
drive okay and we talked about the
collision in this slide maybe so this is
exclusive ta and there's another thing
called composite data about 220
composite ESO composite EA is like in
areas where you may not have adequate
number of MSM you have a single like
exclusivity I for example if there are
only two in the dermis I'm in a
particular area but they are doing the
female sex worker also so then you
combine like 200 plus two and then as a
compass 80s so that's like composite
here so these are two mechanism by which
a mess i mortgaged throughout india so
it's only five base of like they go to
the roofing sites and there are no other
like interventions for among the general
population or even in other male
populations like migraines or prisoners
no there's no like specifically as a
component addressing same-sex behavior
okay you can see the scaling up of
towered intervention so it automatically
increased our only but this is the
government one this one is actually from
other funding agencies for example
majority of them well actually from
allergan the gates foundation project so
only from here actually the government
funding started from 2006 okay this is
about like the approximate number of
agencies working with them a thumbs up
about like 150 organizations are working
with MSM and about the within the 150
about 10 3 organization they also work
with the transgendered people and about
like one-third of them or I think one
maybe half here CBO's on here like
nearly forty six out of the 10 30 CBO's
okay so coming to the coverage of far
like how so how many MSM have been
reached out to the HIV prevention
programs as you might remember like I
mentioned point three million is the
estimated number of like MSM high-risk
MSM by neck up so so by genuinely 2010
through the target intervention
approximately like to 75,000 MSM web
wished so Nikos's so this means
approximately like there's a 78
percentage coverage but if you remember
my they are the estimation of neck or
that MSM estimation was 2.3 million so
this is like only high-risk MSM and from
that gift that was taken of the
denominator and this is the number of em
were some who have reached to the T is
and therefore the coverage is like
family eight percentage does the nichoza
org image okay
he's a maximum about people they can
serve as my new pal how are we getting
275
which one no no no this I am NOT talking
about like organization who are being
funded this in a particular mapping
study they found that this many number
of organizations are working with MSM
and transgender not all these
organizations all find that those were
going to go back one slide again fear
that one oh ok these blue sea ice covers
maximum of 600 MSM and you've got 150 of
them that's only 90,000 so we are we
getting children 78,000 and actually
this is the diff is the yes pictured
coverage is the expected coverage but
some of them they may actually reach out
to like less than 400 yeah so much yep
well something if you're greater number
whether that might be numbers of
contacts and not numbers of unique
individuals I'm not sure ok I actually I
can talk about the controversy behind
the coverage once i finish maybe it's
because i also i also pointed out in my
technical report to wh 0 which so
because there was some complicated
complications in how they calculate the
coverage whether it is reach or whether
it is coverage coverage on what basis
like maybe i will talk about that ok
ok so this I already mentioned like 78
percentage coverage this many number of
people covered is estimated population
in msn ok I'm coming to antiretroviral
treatment access from april two thousand
four nyko started providing free
antiretroviral treatment I neck this is
some neck disney co's data sonechko is
like about 558 travel gender people are
on a Archie in by the end of like 2009
but there's no similar no data for you
my son actually we don't know like
because they don't collect that as part
of the information in Antigua total
treatment centers but but through the
cbo's and the pho networks we observed
that there are several barriers faced by
marginalized groups including MSM in
accessing this free anti victorville
treatment even though it isn't because
the government argument was it is free
anybody can access why they are not
coming forward but there are many such a
posture MSM sex workers inject in the
users who are not using the free anti
virtual treatment because of variety of
recent one common thing was about cha
the stigma that none of stigma both from
the the blotter fofa she was also within
the growing community for example even
if I'm hi jaypaw CMS Sam I'm a nerd to
want to reveal my status even jame won't
peers especially even if I am like MSM
in sex work that that's also going to
affect my livelihood so there are varied
of reasons why people they may not want
to describe the wreckage if Stefan
because then going to anti virtual
treatment center base so like an open
declaration that I am like a.j posture
so this is a this so this one is this is
in place like this one steady with do
blow like on by if two Friel TXS among
MSM another one is in chennai so we have
formed like several reasons for why our
people are not using the available free
article visas okay so coming to the
resources available for na cp3 program I
just wanted to say like one day one
point this is the direct contribute
from the gommage 25 percentage
everything else is coming from the
external donors this may be significant
improvement from in FCP too because in
unity pictured that was actually
virtually no government contribution
government told like nearly 40-percent
is coming from well bank anyway we are
going to pay back the money to Burbank
so that is our contribution so there was
actually virtually no contribution in
energy p 2 but in any cp3 at least like
a does a like twenty five percent
contribution from the government ok
sonechko has like four objectives in NH
cp3 so like prevention treatment
capacity building and strategic
information so you can see like what
percentage of like money available the
budget available is allocated for these
objectives nearly next 70 percentage for
prevention but we actually don't have
any information about how many of these
are earmarked for the various with
groups and also unvarying for Tinley we
don't have any information about which
are the details of the distribution of
funds for emma's arm or other cove
high-risk groups ok so just to summarize
the various gaps and challenges as i
have mentioned like the program the
national program is only like targeting
MSM who are coming to the proofing sites
of the hot spots and majority and the
outreach workers are primarily like cote
identify so you even if i'm like a say
i'm a pantheon a double decker i may not
be want to be seen talking to cody and
into a person without really like
feminine because i will be labeled as
homosexual by others so there are
several issues like why like like the
even though they're implying a peer
approach may not be working so and again
like the MSM from the middle and upper
class of left out come all mostly
completely people who are like get into
fader bisexual
identify and people who may not be
coming to the cuffing sites and
primarily using like other modes of
communication like internet automobiles
all these like all these are like jobs
we are missing out and since on most of
the interval like the intervention
components does not does no actually
might not much talk about this babies
with female partners because the
assumption if we are talking about msn
so the talk needs primarily with the
like this behaviors with male partners
and baby needs a little attention to the
sexual violence like there are no sexual
violence prevention programs or the any
programs to mitigate the consequences of
sexual violence until now like a until
you even know that there's actually none
and this is another major gap is our
lack of any program component in
addressing the mental health issues
faced by MSM so it's primarily only
looking at the Koch IV component you
distribute condoms you talk about HIV
risk and yes Sheriff you don't see that
as a like there is no holistic program
in addressing like other health needs of
MSM so its primary at the individual
level only like you know looking at the
behavioral models okay okay again the
lack of structural interventions to
address a filter stigma and
discrimination against MSM there's no
effect like national program we charge
of the stigma faced by people in with
the trivial other modular clips and
there are several gaps in strategy
information the way I already point out
there's only one so L Center for
transgender people so we don't have much
information and also we don't have any
information about HIV incidence so all
we have seen like hachi prevalence data
it can very well be like there are many
people who are like dying now and then
it doesn't decrease so it doesn't
actually we don't know much about like
the hatching incidents whether it is
decreasing or increasing we don't know
okay but anyway these are the reef and
developments all just
last year there was a major like funding
from Global Fund and this will support
about two hundred three beers in 17
states and there and it's likely to
reach more than point 45 million MSM and
transgender people you can see this more
than the estimate of the neck oh okay so
this is a and it's like about 25 million
dollars for five years and I co have
just started the defining of the in ecp
for so maybe you're hopefully none other
one year like they will incorporate they
will I able to address like all the gaps
in NAC p3 and also now interventions are
being planned to cover hard to each MSM
and women partners of MSM I versa I was
part of some development of some
technical briefs for an echo on why
doesn't need to focus on other
subpopulations of MSM and women partners
of MSM so now when I co is thinking
about like